one boom hello everyone.welcome what's
up
I'm your host Alan Saki and welcome to
simulation today we're sitting down with
Matty McKibben how's it gone out what's
up a minute pleasure to be here thank
you for joining us of course between all
you're like DC and Dubai's and all this
stuff you're finally able to sit down
with us yeah I gave away most of my
things here in the past a couple months
and living the decentralized yeah ematic
lifestyle man but I've been in San
Francisco for about a week week and a
half and so it's perfect timing just sit
down here beautiful yeah I look i we're
gonna show that little tulum graphic the
one on your banner on your facebook yeah
that one I was just sent that like last
week as well by somebody and I thought
it was perfect so we will show that to
you guys I think you will really enjoy
it so Matt's background is great and I
actually never heard of this before but
industrial hygiene at West Virginia
University
that's for hygiene engineering yeah
interesting so I mean like undergrad was
in physics I picked physics I actually
got into West Virginia University out of
state and it was cheaper to go there
that Penn State in state at the time I
was from Altoona Hollidaysburg
Pennsylvania where the slinky was
invented and yeah cheaper I got a small
scholarship and ended up going for
physics I liked math and science and one
of my uncle's was a physicist so just
fell right really hard major actually
yeah figure it out oh yeah and wanted to
switch to engineering couple times my
parents were like no just finish the
degree you can go you can do whatever we
want afterwards and then 2008 everything
crashed it's exactly when I graduated
and went decided to go straight to grad
school I liked health and Health and
Safety I did like protecting people and
this was kind of like the analytical
side of all the health and safety
engineering concepts that I like so tell
us a bit about this like what is
industrial hygiene like you know you
were talking about protecting people
is it literally what were some of these
classes like what were you learning
that's I've never heard of that before
yeah so industrial hygiene you kind of
think of like in my mind I kind of think
of like a giant toothbrush near the I'm
cleaning like big industrial things when
in reality industrial hygiene is the
anticipation recognition and prevention
of hazards within the workplace soy
kosha yeah OSHA is the regulatory body
that that makes the laws around health
and safety in the workplace
NIOSH would be one of the research arms
and there's a lot of different
environmental and and standards that get
put out because it's really hard for
especially the like people that are just
doing their jobs to know exactly how
much they're being exposed so the
example that I wrap yeah yeah the
example I always used is like if you let
med in your welder right how much metal
fumes are you're breathing oh why how
much is dangerous
you don't want how do you know how much
you're breathing and then how do we
prevent you know metal fume fever and
then and and no one you have it in
treated when you have it and by lung
disease yeah yeah new moniker new model
for microscopic still to connect any
osis as the like the longest word in the
English dictionary coal miners disease
silicosis those types of things and I
had a physics background I ended up
working at a nuclear facility as my
first job out of grad school in Ohio and
so in in Ohio they have these nuclear
enrichment facilities Ohio and Kentucky
this is actually a really cool story so
I have to have to tell it yeah they have
these where they enriched all the
uranium from the 19 you know 50 40s 50s
and there's 20,000 20 ton cylinders of
depleted uranium hexafluoride d uf6
sitting outside rusting in a field okay
they're starting to not think I've seen
a photo of this before yeah it's so
they're out there they're rusting and
the Ohio EPA pleaded depleted so it's
it's not enriched uranium this is where
they put the waste essentially but when
depleted uranium hexafluoride do uf6
reacts with moisture in the air it
produces
radioactive hydrofluoric acid gas and so
radioactive so hydrofluoric acid is not
just like a hydrochloric acid where you
get an acid burn HF if you get enough to
cover the palm of your hand enough
surface area you die within 24 hours
without him without being treated right
you can you can treat it so we were we
were taking these 20 tons cylinders of
depleted uranium reacting it with
superheated steam and hydrogen through a
process and making ten thousand gallon
tanks of hydrofluoric acid to sell back
to industry and get rid of this
Heidegger yeah get rid of this very
heavy so the rest in that yeah so that
was my first job I was one of the health
and safety guys there it was an
eye-opening experience you know the
department energy nuclear site and knew
I didn't want to do that for the rest of
my life yeah yeah did that safeties
great but doing it in a way like that
was not of great interest no no it was
and it was it was interesting I ran into
really intelligent people that worked in
the field a lot of Navy nukes really
like hardcore and intelligence people
that have been in you know the bottoms
of Navy subs with nuclear reactors and I
know all of their engineering they know
all of their nuclear physics they know
all of that and was there so it was a
really eye-opening experience but knew I
knew I wanted to do something else was
getting very into what money was in
society being in 2008 like going through
that process as a new young graduate you
go huh
what do you mean they're printing of
trillion dollars and giving it to banks
and how does that even work why is that
legitimate how can we do that
and so it's so it's so overly complex
and it becomes difficult for the average
person to invest any time into learning
it is actually when we're running around
every single day doing the whole nine to
five thing we barely have any
availability to invest into learning
about the system that we even live
mm-hm and that that's a lot of that same
things apply to our these magic boxes
that are our phones and computers now
it's a similar with even legislation
with Congress we don't know we don't
know who's representing us we barely
know who's representing us in the city
we don't know what legislation is being
voted on how it's being voted on how
it's being argued upon who's writing it
it's the it's becoming we need to get
closer and closer to these things and
out further and further away yeah we
need more more transparency and more
ability to interact with that on a on a
level that is not saying well this guy
who happens to be in my local
geographical area represents all of my
decisions in my governance system versus
and this is something that blog chains
and things can eventually help
I think the improve our governance
system so liquid democracy style like
delegating your your rights or your
viewer not right sister but you're
delegating your approvals to maybe a
nonprofit organization that would make
decisions on nuclear safety or on
environmental versus your local
representative that may or may not
represent you in most of your views this
is and this will be an interesting
conversation but the whole process of
the benevolent decision tree as in you
can just throw up your vote to somebody
that you think is benevolent is in their
decisions and they can throw their vote
to the next one it cetera until you get
to maybe one person that's representing
500 or 5,000 people with their vote so
that so that kind of stuff but we can we
look let's look at more about like
liquid democracy and delegated yeah
stuff so with from physics to industrial
hygiene we're dressing out in level a
suits going into the the hazards
material areas taking examples moved to
DC for some money yeah focus of money I
was doing I was getting into a kind of a
libertarian kind of activism phase of my
life was really interested in realizing
that a lot of politicians were just
lying through their teeth and that was
kind of what called did a lot of people
we're talking about all
different economic systems with me sis
and Keynes and Hayek and Austrian versus
Keynes in school and what moved to DC
for a girl that didn't work out but what
you know there was a lot of activists
there and a large like nonprofit
community was doing a radio show called
Liberty panacea on blog talk radio and
talking about our first show was called
what is money where does it come from
you know explain it to me like I'm five
you know if if I if I go to the average
you know mommy daddy what is money and
where does it come from good luck right
it comes from the government kids shut
up right but but you know those kind of
talk so we you know we were trying to
Lansing yeah ago shared shared fiction
and what is a given value and who you
trusting to give that value that's such
a complex system that it's so difficult
to explain like I'm five which is what
we were initially yeah yeah yeah and so
that's what led me to some of these new
decentralized systems Bitcoin in
particular
imagine exploiting a block team you see
oh I live right well and there's
actually a famous article out there
explain Bitcoin to me like I'm five yeah
and they talk about digital apples and
physical apples and how you could take a
digital apple and send it to someone
else but you you're you represent
digital scarcity for the first time so
for every other file that I have I send
it to you you know that I still have I
can send it to ever I want in in
cryptocurrencies it's for the first time
I could send you something in you know
for certain that I don't own it anymore
versus not versus not being precluded
from having a copy of the digital Apple
which it was an unlimited amount of
digital apples and there would be no
scarcity which means anybody could tap
in any time and get as many apples as
they want and then it doesn't function
as a great medium of exchange if we can
all make as much as what it could
function as a in terms of just exchange
as in you tapping and in getting the
digital Apple may be printed to you to
eat whenever you want
a picture of the Apple yeah yeah yeah
but yeah if we could read it pretty good
that's pretty good
the EO like okay cell and so that's
really where I got into to Bitcoin and
decentralized systems because I saw
started a meet-up
certainly meetup so yeah I came in the
meetup they started it in 2011 and I
came in 2012-2013 and there was a lot of
developers was a small group of people
because who knew what Bitcoin was in
2012
especially in DC and came in and a lot
of the developers wanted to develop the
stuff but they weren't exactly people
that wanted to broaden explain the
concepts to you know hundreds of new
people and so I being kind of a person
that liked a lot of people and community
took over and would talk to interesting
people and bring them to speak over the
course of three four five years and then
I'm I'm not based there anymore but I
still like to do events in DC when and
use the the network that we've built and
then how did you manage to figure out
that you wanted to get it become start
descent Renetta yeah yeah that's been a
year now it's been about a year that we
started maybe maybe a little less than a
year I think it was in the middle of the
summer that we kind of like decided on
the name and get all the website and
everything up yeah I mean I from the
2013 on I wanted to get a job in Bitcoin
and blockchain but there weren't really
many jobs you mean you could start your
own company if you knew how to do that
at the time and I was not an
entrepreneur yet I didn't really know
what I was doing there but there were a
lot of companies being formed and I
would just learning everything I
possibly could reading all of the white
papers aetherium came out in 2014 as a
white paper you know invested in the
token sale there so you know putting up
I said my car for Bitcoin in the
beginning of 2014 because I wasn't using
it and he would everybody hear that I
sold my car for Bitcoin
I love it I love it we actually recently
heard a story from Dan Gailey who who
taught us that some kid went the very
young kid went and grabbed his mom's
credit card and he he sacrificed his
relationship with his mother so that he
could go and buy crypto off online
what a interesting story roadie figure
out he banked didn't he didn't he make a
lot of money what he stole he stole
money from his mother's credit card but
that's I think so
but yeah it in and how exactly what what
to what extent are people willing to go
to enter this field yeah I saw it as an
opportunity I wasn't using the car very
much anyway I was take Ebru was really
taking off in DC so I was you know it
was blocked to from the grocery store I
would use it maybe occasionally to drive
home to Pennsylvania to see my parents
where I can rent a car you know for the
weekend if I needed to do that so I sold
it it was a whole ten thousand dollars
or something at the time I had property
taxes in Arlington there's like a 60%
car property tax in Arlington so I was
like I'm not paying this and and so yeah
and then got involved as many different
types of like companies whatever I could
do to help promote it and talk about it
I worked for fact Tom and so in 2017 a
detainee is another company that I
helped found with Brock Pierce
decentralized the numeron him for
decentralizes detainee like indrasen
Horowitz is a 16z and so that company
has taken off this year and did my last
one in August of last year the startup
societies and so I was getting all these
advisory clients people were saying oh
can you help me with their eyes the ICO
and since you we've been around since
the first couple ones we at least had
the knowledge of like hey you're doing
this right or how you're doing this
wrong they need to get this audited by
these technical partners and so my
friends who I had been who had started
their own software business a couple
years ago we're now doing business
advisers
and I said wall these are all the
projects that I could potentially work
on and yeah we're dropping everything
let's do that yeah yeah so you had you'd
built out a pretty solid network of
people that knew kind of how to launch a
blockchain companies or decentralized
companies and then across all the
different aspects of the actual icao
across legal across marketing across all
these fields and then you were able to
plug them in as they went and so that's
why you've started this blocking
consultancy yeah yeah because it's a
complex process there's you know some of
the best lawyers and that even changes I
mean over the past year at the beginning
of 2017 doing an IC o---- you weren't
really talking to a bunch of lawyers
there might be some to make sure you
weren't flaming and as a security but as
long as you were kind of framing it as a
token sale pre-purchase of software it
was fine by the end of the year there
was a new thing called assaf the safe
agreement for future tokens but that
didn't exist at the beginning of 2017
and the marketing partners a lot of a
lot like crowdfunding in a lot of ways
in terms of the way you want to do it
you wanted to preload a lot of the
purchasers so that it looked like you
were gonna get like you had the first
couple million already in the first day
then they that was a prediction let's
explain this for people watching so walk
us through what exactly tokens are and
how many usually accompany its is it
analogous to a share of a company as
they make whatever 10 million shares
when you first make your company and
then you can distribute those as you
want is a token analogous to that etc
yeah so I mean a token itself is a
digital fixed scarce digital asset that
you're pretty much bootstrapping a
network or an economy I wouldn't
analogize it to really a share you don't
have any voting rights necessarily and
usually tokens definitely don't give you
some sort of share of a dividend or
anything like that it's more like create
a decentralized network that
disintermediate s-- middlemen in making
so let's say you had a broker a broker
service that ana massive industry like
saying the shipping industry is one of
the the companies that we're working on
that i think is a really good example
there's a lot of different brokers and
they silo information about who the best
you know shippers and and truckers and
all of our you could create a
decentralized marketplace where the on a
peer-to-peer basis people can use tokens
to say put into escrow if they don't
trust that person or they have a rating
and they can then take those tokens and
use them as payment but you you're not
necessarily relying on central parties
to hold the information tokens are
usually a part of a fixed kind of
economy where let's say you issue a
billion tokens you're saying that you're
not going to issue anymore that's the
total amount of tokens and you issue
them say at a certain price let's say a
penny and you're saying that this
economy is going to be about you know
this but that much in value currently
and you don't necessarily know but
you're issuing that people can purchase
these tokens a lot of times there are
credits for the software to use that
economy and if they think that there's
gonna be more demand for these fixed
amount of tokens later you know the
value of those tokens would relatively
go up if more people wanted to use this
network software system a lot of the
ones in the beginning were very much
like entry credits to open source
software so you would say okay well
we're gonna in order to use our software
system you have to purchase these
credits and the more people that you
want to use our software system the
higher the value because there's a fixed
amount of them it sounds like a pretty
good way to start the token system is
once you make a scarce amount of 1
billion of them then you can say that in
order to use our service that we're
providing you must get 20 of these
tokens which is equivalent to 20 US
dollars or whatever and then you get 20
of them and then all of a sudden then
people have become
invested into the service and they're
giving it more value in its person the
perceived value is higher and that's
kind of how the company can fund more of
their R&D more people coming in and
getting it over time yeah and a lot of
them were foundations so they would say
oh we're open source software so we're
going to set up a foundation and then
we'll build this this network this
economy and then we'll have for-profit
entities or a for-profit company come in
and and maybe build services on top of
this open source network that were oh
wow that's cool so that's why then you
don't get the data silos you don't get
the vertical marketplaces you get the
horizontal ones you get the open-source
movement so what you build with your
white paper and what you're trying to
impact the world with is all
decentralized all open-source technology
and then you have an entity that comes
in on top of that that then tries to do
something related to making some money
in software or whatever but all the
underlying guts are open source for
other people to come and build entities
on top of all its services exchanges
security professionals there's a lot of
different services you can build on top
of it so for example Bitcoin or
aetherium in the etherium foundation was
what issued the original aetherium
tokens they sold them for Bitcoin and
then they launched the network and on
top of aetherium you can then build
decentralized applications on top you
can issue your own tokens but there's no
the theory of network or theorem
foundation is a foundation to kind of
like the mozilla foundation to the linux
foundation to manage the open source
software of that and then free profit
businesses can come on and build
applications for consumers and for
businesses
I really like that example I think
that's a really relatable one so okay so
was this two thousand twelve or thirteen
of aetherium foundation aetherium white
paper came out in end of 2013-2014 than
they did their token sale in June
of 2014 I believe okay so so in so then
in 2014 then aetherium offers a scarce
amount of tokens yep there was a
physical and I don't remember the exact
amount but they offered a certain amount
in the token sale a certain amount go to
the founders a certain go towards
development and marketing and the only
goal yes and and that's usually what you
do with your package as well as you
package it out like that as well we
advise on how much because you don't
want the founders to get 30% of all the
tokens you can get instantly rich when
they haven't really necessarily even
them sold through them themselves and
provided a real product and I guess what
a lot of I SEOs have you know there have
been a lot of people that have taken a
large portion and they haven't
necessarily deliver not a product yeah
but they did that I don't know exactly
what the exact numbers were for the
etherium foundation but they did deliver
right within a year the etherium
launched I believe their thing in 2015
and I don't remember what the exact
price was I remember when I purchased I
think one Bitcoin was $600 and you got
2000 aetherium per Bitcoin for a Bitcoin
yeah well then so you would invest a
Bitcoin get 2000 the theorem tokens and
then with those tokens typically you
would hold on to those tokens because
there wasn't anything you could really
do with them right away
ether wasn't really you weren't really
using it yeah it was basically just a
wallet file it was all a file and then
that the you believe really believed
into what the etherium foundation had
built as that guts for other people to
build decentralized apps using yeah that
was it so so that seems to be a a pretty
good way to
to build a decentralized platformers to
open-source do you think they have to go
hand in hand yeah I think that the the
reason why we have tokens and we have
these these units of these things is
because we can now incentivize open
source software whereas before we we
wanted people to use our open source
everyone and developers to come on but
we you can't necessarily it wasn't it
wasn't profitable and you couldn't
necessarily incentivize people to build
so the Mozilla thought you know
Foundation they they've made a lot of
money they've generations there's
there's profitable businesses they're
Linux it's the same way but it's not the
same as issuing a token and
incentivizing people to come on and
creating bounty programs for them to
build you know a certain smart contract
or audit something it's it's it's now a
way of incentivizing
open source software and open sourcing
of money really that's money and the
internet of money and the other internet
money under SSL was such a good book
yeah initially yeah one of my favorite
books that I read last year highly
recommend intern money highly recommend
book of Satoshi really to get started
for me those were great ok so you were
just touching on this and I thought it
was really good the as we were talking
about earlier with money it's a shared
hallucination
so with tokens is the same thing it's
are just perceived value whatever were
is is there more demand for it okay
great the value of it increases so we're
just perceiving a shared hallucination
on if a developer wants to come on board
we can offer them a reward of some
tokens to help build what we're building
and then the idea is that oh now we have
another developer that developers
building out more value so now our
overall token price increases yeah I
mean it's a shared hallucination I would
say that the with Bitcoin and aetherium
and the other lots of different other
protocols out there your your dis
to mediating a lot of the central
authorities that would normally have to
manage it which are really expensive
that take a lot of management to take a
lot of middleman fees to do it yes
deserve the central bank's just the
banking industry that corn corn if a
foundation does not take a fee so I mean
no though they they have a certain
amount of Bitcoin there are people I
think that have donated to them and and
the foundation of them and you found the
foundation has a certain amount of the
core mount of torrents that to manage
the software but they're not just out of
business right it's the foundation to to
do that and the value that we get from
these systems is that pretty much anyone
it's a payment systems and aetherium is
also a payment system that you can write
if then statements for smart contracts
it's the most basic one that I like to
talk about is is a vending machine so if
you put a dollar into a vending machine
you put the you press the you know one
you get a Snickers bar a quorum or a
bundle of kale and sit right there a
bundle of kale or snapchat glasses right
but you that's the most basic kind of
understanding of what a smart contract
is if I do this then these conditions
are met and then but so but you're
trusting that the vending machine
software will give you that you're not
looking at the code of the vending
machine software you're trusting that
the company who put that there
do it with aetherium you're saying
you're writing these these contracts and
smart contracts and then you're running
it on the etherium virtual machine so
that anyone can look at the code and say
yes this contract when it's executed
will do these things that we know
because we can look at out the code and
so I mean I was just trying to think of
a reason why we need to know that Matt
bought a Snickers at 3 p.m. today
because that that is a one of an
argument yeah
I was under the this this kind of
concept of evolution hasn't really kept
a blockchain around and we only have
humans today and all these other species
but so many species what is it like 90
million species have died in the past
and up until now and now we only have
like 10 million or whatever so the
general idea is that we haven't kept a
blockchain of evolution but for for
example why would it be important to
keep a file on hand of you purchasing a
Snickers at 3 o'clock that that burns
electricity that the storing that data
is irrelevant but or could it be
relevant if a health care company wanted
to know that you were buying Snickers
and they would be like no you shouldn't
have eaten that 50 grams of sugar right
right well and we don't necessarily know
that I bought the Snickers bar on there
it just shows a transaction and in the
payment the the theorem network is
processing that transaction but you
would have actually using your ether in
order to buy it yeah but it isn't
necessary Thur is not necessarily tied
to my identity necessarily it's it's
pseudo anonymous in the sense that like
with a credit card they with the credit
card your name and address and all that
stuff is tied to it credit cards were
not designed through the internet yeah
with cryptocurrencies specifically
Bitcoin in aetherium you have an address
you can tie it to your name specifically
but you don't necessarily have to tie
that that's your address you can start a
new one each time they start a new one
each time a lot of people they want to
protect their identity or protect what
they're doing they could say anytime you
pay me I could start a new I can just do
a new address
that's still managed by the same private
keys so I can have a private key that
has a public key that I can change for
every time that I want somebody to pay
that public key yep and you still have
control under there under the other
thing so if you wanted to do that so
good luck to your question we don't
necessarily need to know what the the
disintermediation of trust of saying
well I don't
I have to trust someone else's
businesses business software official if
I'm doing very large processes I don't
have to trust them I trust the math that
is the the decentralized network instead
of having to trust the centralized
energy to keep the books and the records
for me okay so let's say you're buying
the actual vending machine because
that's an that's a larger good and so
that that you care more about it than
the little Snickers bar so let's say the
vending machines whatever ten thousand
dollars and then so now walk us through
this process what's the difference
between it being centralized owned by a
company that's selling you the vending
machine with an if-then statement of you
pay five thousand or ten thousand you
get the vending machine that's usually
what the contract is I would just say
that that's the vending machine software
is the the most simplest form to
understand what a smart contract is so
the vending machine is running software
that when it gets inputs it does a
couple things and it spits out an output
if I was going to be purchasing a
vending machine in it in itself which
has that software on it you know you
just would go through the whatever
supply chain that the vending machine
company does that's just I was just like
to use that as the simplest form of what
a smart contract its Bitcoin is I can
send you this unit of account and you
know that I sent it there but I can't
really attach rules to why and how and
when it should be set other than when I
send it with aetherium I can say if
these conditions are met please send the
two aetherium to Alan's address so
that's the general idea that it was not
there before is that I can now have a
digital ledger that people agree on that
says that I paid you for a vending
machine yeah and there's a there's a
proof forever that all I have to do is
send you the URL of the the purchase and
say yeah I send it to you here's the URL
I don't know it's really easy to keep
the accounting in that sense because
you're just like did you pay me boom
done and yeah I'm not trusting that you
had the right Google excel sheet and you
you typed in the numbers but that
doesn't necessarily mean that
it transferred this means so much for
accounting and governance and money and
exchange and so many other things how
about you walk us through so let's you
know let's go ahead and what we'll do is
we'll pull up we'll pull up the center
net sure and then we'll we'll show here
kind of what you guys are who you're
working with right now because it's a
lot of one of you up on the alright yeah
and there's there's a lot of companies
there that are on there and then we've
signed a bunch of clients and in the
past couple of months that I think
haven't yet been represented on there so
this internet you know it can kind of go
over specifically what we're about we
like to solve the we want to solve the
greatest challenges using blockchain
technology so we're really interested in
impact focused technology so energy and
healthcare and financial inclusion and
education these types of blockchain
projects that are really having a
massive impact on someone when they're
successful one of the things that I
always kind of say is you there are
video game tokens for example and they
make the video game transferring value
on a video game system more efficient
that's solving a problem in there but
one of our clients that I'd like to use
impact PPA which is a decentralized
energy and I'm not sure if they're
specifically listed there there they are
kind of like decentralized m-pesa for
energy so they've been they just turned
the lights on in laser Hwa Haiti they
turned the powered some hospitals inside
of in Africa and so what we can say that
we have 10 million tokens that were
offering and that every time you fund
the purchase of a token that is funding
the development of the hospital or
the electrical grid or of the
educational institution so they yeah
they they are selling they're selling
they have two tokens one is a credit and
one is credit token that kind of funds
the development of these energy systems
and one of the things that you can it's
really interesting they have like a
solar panel and then they have a wind
thing that also goes with it they have a
live demo where you show you say I want
to get one hours worth of power from
these and it has a battery and a smart
meter on it as well I want to get one
hour for the power when I buy that and
I'm in something they haven't won it set
up in India on top of a roof and they go
okay I'm gonna have enough credits to
buy one house with the power I go with
my fellow cell phone I click Boop and I
the the light turns on and they have 1
hours with the power you could buy one
week you can take a purchase power
agreement and put it on two on theorem
application on your smartphone and buy
whatever power that you need in a very
precise way and then they have these
individual units with solar and I said
clear wind and a battery power that can
go around around the world they can be
hooked together and so that's one of the
cool things so when you invest or when
you purchase some of these different
tokens not only are you you potentially
can make some money is an impact
investment you know but you are also
funding energy in places that has never
been energy before or hasn't it hasn't
been destroyed by hurricanes and yeah
it's been a while since they've been
able to have reliable energy and so
these decentralized energy grids that
are going around in the world they are
it's amazing it's gonna be able to have
create these entities that have power
that's separate from some sort of
license a centralized energy grid that
may or may not be great for the
environment it could be diesel it could
be you know really polluting
the Caribbean islands there's a lot of
those yeah wow that's really fascinating
I'm so grateful for the technology being
leveraged for impact around the world
that's immediately influential on
people's lives like that and that that
is that as incredible tell us more about
the projects yeah and so like over time
loki is a really interesting one we kind
of talked we they did their ICO a late
last last year and they're being they're
using a getting giving liquidity for
intellectual property so let's say
you're inventor and you're inventing
something in a makerspace and you've
come up with something you can search
the history of patents hmm in their
potential search algorithm and see what
you know if it has already been and made
and all the different components that
would come to make that specific thing
and then you can register and the idea
is to have liquidity on that patent
pretty quickly because you can have the
prior art immediately registered and
people can come in and and purchase the
tokens the people that purchase the
tokens of that of their system once it's
registered that intellectual property
would be ideal would be kind of liquid
they're still building the system
building every day I've talked to the
team and they're getting partnerships
with a lot of universities right now I'm
going to the USPTO Eunice's Patent and
Trademark Office and I'm doing a keyword
search to try and find whether or not
somebody has already made the thing that
I'm looking to build what's the
difference here they have more advanced
algorithms to search for the ideas on
there they've been building this system
for I think since 2009 before the
blockchain stuff that the blockchain
tokenization porn is part is new so easy
search intuitive you can dig deeper you
can identify things so they've taken
that that search and
instead so then once I search for let's
say a new surge protector let's say the
guy had designed a new surge protector
so then I look up surge protector on
Loki vert instead of the USPTO and then
from there they show me what that's
unique and different what do they show
me I mean then you can take a look at
that what they're doing there I would
say surge protector would probably be
too generic in what they're doing so
they used the example of a bike what
goes into the different portions of how
a bicycle there would be handlebars
there's the gears there's no pedals
there's all those things that have amout
like have basically been had to have
been invented in some ways it's
visualizing your you the patents and
what areas kind of they fit in where
that which ones overlap and the
different yep and which ones are total
outliers as well of all of them that's
cool no ifs they they're just working I
mean a lot of these companies that have
said raised their funds they're now
building there's the whole meme of hold
huddling yeah now there's the the meme
of okay once you've raised your money
you got a bill doll or whatever that's
reversing the L in the D there it's
really important to do that and and
never forget to actually execute
actually build right just hold another
word one that I love to discuss
specifically is light start yeah our
friends yeah martine they're building
kind of a tech layer for the mental
health industry and tokenizing in game
applying mental health practices and and
I would say meditative and and and
modules that are going to go into
helping you do your therapies they're
gonna integrate that with the upcoming
MDMA and psilocybin and ketamine
psychotherapy centers that will be
legalized and I think in in
is already legalized and MDMA Maps has
raised all of their money for their face
three trials of MDMA so yeah it's like a
therapy which is curing PTSD yes
ketamine yeah that's Special K yeah and
that's that's legal they're they're
using it in a very controlled clinical
environment and it's it's curing
depression severe depression you give
them a dose you that they all the other
treatments haven't worked give them the
doses and through psychotherapy they can
kind of they can come out of the they've
shown that the severe depression goes
away after I'm depressed and then you
may one specifically set with 70 percent
cure rate of PTSD no symptoms after
three sessions how many millions or
billions of dollars we spend on
depression and anxiety and and those
types of things so I'm really excited
for the various sessions that your son
Curie yep
a lot of the veterans ibogaine
treatments curing opioids addictions
with ibogaine treatments that's gonna be
a really big thing this year as well
using these bands essentially medicines
for 30-40 years I kind of call it the
psychedelic Renaissance that's going on
because you know we haven't been able to
really study the effects and we're
finding out the theater really amazing
Renaissance really amazing tools for I
love for the brain and for people I know
it's very popular in the Bay Area
specifically in Silicon Valley for like
the micro dosing of different types of
of those chemicals as like a you know
super creative cup of coffee kind of
thing right you know they people talk
about that and
Tim Ferriss talked about it a lot as
well yep
and then I guess there's one other one
that we kind of talked about beforehand
that we can discuss that's a really cool
concept was securin see the security
i've been working with for over a year
the guy that invented it D'Antoni he
ended up he was working for the NSA at
one point helped build some of the
foundations of the technology for watson
for IBM was a mit nuclear engineer navy
nuke was the first chief innovation
officer of the Defense Intelligence
Agency so looking at all these crazy
technologies and now he wants to
decentralized the world so he's on our
side right and so he's built this new
and he saw that a lot of these tokens
are gonna be security they're gonna be
the cookies are securities and so he's
built a platform that allows you to
liquidity enhance different types of
illiquid assets so if you took like a
revenue stream so my token would be a
liquid well now say your token would be
a liquid let's say you had a commercial
real estate lease and you had that you
had you get payments every month for the
lease and a couple years of and that's
that's a liquid asset you don't you
can't have liquidity you don't
necessarily can't take that and say I
wanted to sell off so much money right
this much money or it would cost a lot
of money to liquidate that they've
created a regulation technology platform
that does the KYC and AML for you to
make sure that and then in the backend
allows you to basically tokenize
something that usually and and liquidize
something that we usually would not be
liquid so using microfinance giving
people loans and places that they've you
know never had it they always used the
example of in like Pakistan where the in
terms of an impact thing in Pakistan
where there's these farmers and they
have these loan shark generational
intergenerational loan sharks that kind
of give them the money for their seed
crops you can finally give them some
real capital that's not a hundred
percent interest and
you know will attack your family or
something like that if you don't pay or
your father's debts or your debt somehow
and that's from one of the ones that
services with the school and so they're
they're building a really really
interesting platform for securities that
one would mainly for illiquid markets
like the one of the things that they're
they're they're partnering with is the
London football exchange they're gonna
be able to tokenize you're gonna go to
own part of your soccer your football to
you which is really interesting you know
the fans can own own part of the stadium
or part of the team those like the Green
Bay Packers yeah exactly and they're
just doing this on kind of a
international market for with with Bach
trains so that's cool so this is what is
this like 16 how many total companies
now are we I think we have about 15 16
clients currently that we're advising
and helping to wait to connect so like
on our web page or you know it shows
that we help with smart contracts and
strategic partnerships and capital
raising and I don't you know we don't
really do all of those things ourselves
but we have really trusted partners that
can kind of go through the process you
and say hey they're really good at this
portion this is really good at this
portion and it's kind of like making a
movie in these tokenized economies know
when we all kind of work together and
then the token sale launches and the
economy launches we all win we all have
created something that hopefully is
creating enough value and
disintermediating you know old ways of
doing commerce that we don't create this
and we all kind of own a portion of it I
found that the less that you own if you
try to like own a lot of it then that
work doesn't work you got to give it
away you got to make sure that a lot of
people are invested into the network to
make it to make it work and so you want
to incentivize lots of people to help
with your your your token sale and your
economy yeah
this is about 16 15 16 orgs are now
using the blotching consultancy so feel
like this is a market that's going to go
a couple well maybe an order magnitude
up in just the next year or so
blockchain consultancies yep so cuz I
don't think anybody was thinking of that
not anybody but very few people were
thinking of that even just a couple
years ago and this is good now we have
an incredible list of these clients that
you're serving and they're serving the
world with their technologies I'm I'm
finding a lot of the examples that you
listed to be really interesting let's
talk about some of the some of what's
going on right now in let's do let's ask
about this first and then we'll kind of
venture down so yeah so we have tons and
tons of different icos and just
cryptocurrencies that exist in general
right now that are out there and this
kind of reminds me of when currency
first birth into the world where people
were exchanging whatever unit of value
they wanted for whatever goods and then
their births you know so many different
types of currencies and the your
currency doesn't work here in this part
of the world etc and then now it seems
to be pretty ubiquitous it's just one
currency per country pretty much is kind
of the this sort of you know there's
only whatever a couple hundred
currencies in the world d do you think
that we're gonna go from the massive 1
million different types of currencies
down to only a couple dozen of the
currencies in terms of what we exchange
for value of course there will always
still be all the other ones that are
specialized tokens for their one thing
that they're doing yeah so let's let's
unpack that a little bit currencies you
know have evolved over thousands and
thousands of years there's been
different attributes that have really
defined better mediums of exchange
versus worse you want to have you want
have durability you want have
portability you want to have
divisibility for those types of
currencies so you know grains of salt
would be great or pieces of gold land
she's not exactly portable but you can
divide it and Aristotle kind of divided
things fungibility one ounce of gold is
always worth one ounce of gold one
Bitcoin there's always one Bitcoin one
dollar is always one dollar and so those
are those are important factors with the
internet of money and this is what
crypto currencies Bitcoin and aetherium
and all things I think that has kind of
unleashed how many blogs do we have how
many websites do we have and so if we
have a protocol for value exchange on
the internet and anyone can create a
community currency and make it liquid
with the rest of the world and I can
have my community currency over here
that normally would only be good in this
one geographical area but now using
something like Bank or which is a
platform that you can create your own
digital currency community currency and
then you can always have make it liquid
with everything else and a lot of the
internet of of block chains I think that
we'll see thousands millions of
different types of currencies and
exchange of value and I think that one
of the main things that's happening is
we're seeing we're going to see what
that humans value change and how we
determine value change because we're
seeing a lot of loss of jobs of
automation and
and robotics and and artificial
intelligence and so how do we value
humans worth if it's not their ability
to you know say data entry or to you
know serve you at some assembly line if
those things are automated how do we how
do we ensure that that humans can still
create value for what we're doing and so
I think that with these types of
different cryptocurrencies and tokens
and all the different kind of new
vocabulary that we're using to describe
this system some of which works is some
of it's still kind of pulling this
legacy language and trying to use it in
this new system I think we can
incentivize what we want to value in the
distance different systems that we
create and that's gonna be really
important we don't necessarily have the
right incentive structures all of our
systems in society currently how would I
how would I take an Allen token and give
it to how a simulation token in addis
entrant i would they play i mean so we
need to center net tokens so we don't
have any rights but if you were gonna
create it i mean there would be some
sort of exchange rate to some sort of
base level protocol like aetherium or
yes or whatever and if they were going
to be exchanged for each other i go back
down to the base if they're not I think
I'm gonna go back out and the value of
the the exchange rate would be I would
would be the sum of the supply and then
the demand of the token and whatever
monetary policy that was created and
Indian if you're if the the the center
of that token in particular was solving
some really big problem and a lot of
people needed to use it for that
ecosystem then there would be more
demand versus you know if the simulation
depending on what the simulation and so
there might might have different values
but ultimately it's going to be the the
supply and demand of the of the token so
ultimately I have my
digital wallet and then my digital
wallet has a base aetherium and then at
any point I can go and get other tokens
or get other goods or values or services
with my base level currency getting
their tokens or their service if it's
liquid if you're using something like
Bank or some of these tokens that exist
now they're not being listed on
exchanges very easily and so they're not
liquid or what they are listed on an
exchange there's not a lot of there's
not a lot of the tokens on there so if
you if you owned one hundred thousand of
the tokens and there's only fifty you
know there's only two hundred thousand
being listed on the exchange
you're gonna massively drastically
change the price by selling it to come
and so liquidity is is king in this
thing and so creating systems that can
ensure that you have liquidity when when
you want to sell is really important
okay all right I think that is a pretty
decent floor into that realm of
conversation and it's it's it's more
difficult can take us a while to unpack
it so let's let's go on to the 99 to one
because I think that's very relatable to
what we were just talking about it's it
does seem as though there are more and
more people that figure out how to be
the black sheep when they see the 99
sheep moving one way what is the black
sheep doing moving the other way that
could potentially be right that the
other white sheep are not figuring out
to be right and is there one of those
black sheeps in the cryptocurrency and
blockchain market so unpack this I want
to make sure that I have the right
concept so the the the one sheep going
it's the one that sees what's going on
and is right and tens up making money on
it whenever one else goes oh my god he's
right is that wasn't yeah maybe it's
like you know maybe a good example would
be there's these 99 sheeps that are all
trying to you know start icos and get a
decentralization and block
and there's one person that is observing
that and thinking like what is gonna
happen there that is not being expected
that is not being thought about and how
can I help address that thing so it or
there's that aspect of looking at
there's also the aspect of the so many
different coins exist versus the
foundation of just Bitcoin and aetherium
being these two that are gonna live on
forever versus so yeah I mean so a lot
of these tokens are created on top of
aetherium or on top of Bitcoin or on top
of Nia or all these other types of
systems so ultimately it they're they're
they're they're based on top of those so
aetherium may live on forever bitcoin
may live on forever but ultimately I
think that those third generation kind
of blockchains one for improving if
we're at the net skip escape level
there's gonna be a lot of other
applications that and and protocols that
are built out that in and matured there
the I think that the ones that actually
build and and and execute and create
economies and actually have solved a
problem will be the ones that that
continue to go on but I think that
probably 90% of tokens will probably go
to zero at least 90% of startups fail
right not out of 10 and so these are
highly speculative and risky endeavors
they just happen to be really
capitalized right usually you don't get
five to ten million dollars to try to
start your startup right with a white
paper and a website so they're highly
capitalized they may go on for a little
while but as time goes on I think
that'll most of these type tokens that
someone has launched from their basement
that maybe I put a team together will go
to zero because they
they haven't necessarily thought out all
of the different problems and aren't
necessarily disagree da ting some some
metric and won't necessarily be used
that's just my opinion
but roll asleep yeah what do you think
about the start of societies that are
starting to blossom now around the world
um I really want to pull up that graphic
now cuz it's just too funny we've got it
we've got to pull it up I'm wearing
actually the the last one of the shirts
that I've been wearing a lot it's the
start up society's foundation detainee
the last event that I did for detainee
yeah in August
it says tokenize this but and the there
are a lot of movements to create
intentional communities around the world
Puerto Rico being one of them and lots
of in Central and South America there's
people that are creating kind of an
entire community with like decentralized
energy goods they want to create their
own kind of governance protocols on top
of blockchain and there's a lot of
people that as you can see have kind of
chosen to decentralize they're like
alright well then someone sent me this
like when it came out like ten people
sent it to me and we're like hey the
beamed you they beamed you they did they
memed you that is you right there yeah
but uh so so so these so these startup
societies in different beautiful places
in the world but also in in places in
the world that really need the attention
of sustainability and energy and
resources and time but the general gist
of it is that there for example like
Tulum in New Mexico is one of these
places it's a very beautiful beach
resort on the Caribbean there's some
Mayan ruins there's all this cool stuff
there and it's still very you know not
it's not urbanized yet you know a lot of
people go there
the general gist is you know this is the
guy that's like I've been called to
decentralize my lifestyle and trust the
Divine Feminine in you honors my high
vibration and reticence for open
relations resonance for open
relationships now where's the cuddle
puddle where's the cuddle these guy Palo
Santo micro dosing maybe Maha beads
crystal and it says former tech bro
turned enlightened nomadic shamanic DJ
life coach entrepreneur and Alchemist
and I think you know they and she's
sitting here going you don't need
another ayahuasca ceremony you need to
leave Tulum and so this has become a
pretty famous kind of meme and they've
actually changed a lot of the there's
one for a female one and they've changed
a lot of the stuff in different versions
of it but yeah they're they're
exemplifying that there's a lot of
people that have kind of started running
around the world have taken to a very
spiritual place I've done a lot of these
different types of plant medicines have
become a a nomadic person because they
decided they wanted to travel when
they're you know late 20s early 30s and
they they're there's a lot of people out
there like that and I think it's going
to continue the more people that are
able able to travel and and go around
the world and use these new dementia
lized remote technologies you know do
work well but it's definitely a great
meme for perfectly the the people that
have done it and have have created that
so we'll see where these form because
you know Peter Thiel talks a lot about
when is this network effect starting to
actually not be worth it as in is it
worth the $4,000 a month to live in the
one bedroom in San Francisco I actually
think it is I am like I'm contrarian in
that sense I think the network effect is
absolutely crazy I think it's totally
worth every penny to grind in hustle to
you can find a one bed you can find a
bed
room inside of a house of like five
bedrooms two bathrooms for only a
thousand or a thousand three hundred or
something a month so it's not as obscene
as its being as being made out to be in
many cases but I think it's worth every
single penny for the network effect in
the area and then the next question is
when is it going to be that so many
people add that are part of this network
effect of these tech grows turned
shamanistic lovers of reality and
everything when when are when are when
is that going to move to you know other
hubs like fricken Omaha and Nebraska and
when is that going to move to the board
like all these border cities by Mexico
or when is that gonna move to Tulum and
when's I going to move to other parts of
the world and will the network effect
keep up as in when Tulum becomes ma
herbin eyes first of all will income
high I hope not I like to live as it is
in terms of its it's a very kind of I
would say it's a very environmentally
conscious place if you tried to urbanize
it like Cancun I think would ruin it's
kind of via especially with all the like
Mayan ruins and all that kind of stuff
there I don't know I would just say that
there are lots of like we work and
Salinas and different types of companies
that are preparing for the remote worker
and that more and more people if they
can choose to travel for a couple of
years will I do think that in San
Francisco the dairy is a massive network
effect and there's a benefit of being
here especially for a specific type of
startup and whenever I'm here I it's
hard for me to leave because there's so
much going on and there's so many
interesting people that you run into
just that at events and so there will be
always concentrations of innovation and
different hubs but I do see that
spreading out and I do see service
providers like said we work such we live
making
making facilities for these digital
nomads that can do all their work from a
laptop wherever they are in the world
and as these sustainability like I
really want to see these sustainable
communities build them as long as they
have internet and a nice place to stay
you can be on a beach and be working
think so Tulum as long as they do it
sustainably and they don't really damage
the the ecosystem there there's a lot of
national parks and cenote those are
gorgeous yeah and I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to urbanize that destroy that with
a lot all of a sudden the ecosystems
will change once there is more and more
alcohols and on chemicals and all these
other kinds of things that are spilled
over into those areas the the ecosystems
will change and then biodiversity will
change and then also will potentially
pollute it with plastics cos we're not
fully transitioned to biodegradable
although we did just post a video about
about these really cool plates that are
being made over in India where they're
stamping to the other leaves interested
and they're sewing together these leaves
which they've been eating off leaves for
a long time but each plate is less than
$1 biodegrades and under 4 weeks which
is super impressive we've been really
trying to push for that movement but the
problem is is that everybody wants to
increase their [ __ ] bottom line and
if you're gonna use a paper plate that
is throwaway or a plastic plate or
styrofoam plate that is gonna cost you
one penny it's gonna take 50 years to
degrade and it's gonna pollute the [ __ ]
out of ecosystems but if you use a $1
plate and you fork over that other part
of your bottom line it will be better
for the ecosystem so how can we figure
out how to where to charge people a
little bit more or whatever in order to
do that so I'm glad that that brought us
there I'm glad that we loop together the
startup societies because I feel like we
need to go when we do it and do it
responsibly in a way that mixes together
the ecology with the business in a
sustainable way and I think that we are
this enlightened nomadic
shaman ik tribal people that go over
there and do it that way I hope so
or engage the local community people it
would be is the most important thing
just going in going to a place if you're
there's a ton of people that go there
it's seen as something like taking over
versus helping to build their community
a sustainable way you know that we want
to make sure that happens but yeah
exactly
building you know sustainable systems
with the technology from the ground up
with these communities is really
important and as far as like the the
paper plates and styrofoam plates
figuring out ways to incentivize people
to purchase the right things is the way
to do it and I think that crypto
currencies will eventually create
incentive systems to do that either by
paying people more money to incentivize
them to do it maybe with a with some
sort of token that that rewards you for
for using the sustainable one or by you
know tracking how many of these other
companies aren't producing the maybe
charging more for the environmental
because it's a negative externality that
we don't see in our price right we don't
see if you're using a Styrofoam plate
you're not seeing the damage that it
does to the ocean or the passes of the
plastics you're using you're not just
seeing the damage that it would cost to
take it yeah yep to clean it up yeah so
we're doing let's do a little dive into
crypto psychedelics as well yeah yeah so
there was you hosted your first annual
event yeah and that was where was it
when was it and what did you guys talk
about there and are you guys all just
micro dosing and talking about crypto no
no I I think it's it's way more academic
than that and so the the origin of this
was that we did a fundraiser cruise
formats in August called the crypto
psychedelic cruise and we were getting
we had some you know different visionary
artists on board and we'd through a
fundraising event to
is money for MDMA phase three trials you
may psychotherapy from that I connected
with the guys from symposia which is a
psychedelic advocacy website and I
wanted to throw another on an event down
in and we're in Tulum I had been to be
hearing about to live I wanted to go to
Tulum to see what it was like and so on
February 3rd we threw the first ever
initial event offering is what we called
it
ie o of crypto psychedelic crypto
psychedelic calm is the website do mob
and really we flew down some of the
world's most renowned academic
researchers and scientists Dennis
McKenna Katherine MacLean there were
some people from maps Natalie Ginsburg
was there that have been really studying
all of the science that's been going on
and doing the science through the
traditional means we also then invited a
lot of the cryptocurrency people
community to come down and talk about
what this new technology is how it works
a lot of people have made obviously a
lot of money and so donating to maps was
something that we really wanted people
to do much did raise all of the money
through the pineapple fund and the other
donations pi will fund donated and I
think ended up donating a total of five
million dollars to Matt's amazing and so
it was really a collaboration of these
people that had been researching and
studying these tools that we have these
medicines that have been banned and this
new form of money and incentive systems
and governance systems to see how we can
do not only fund the science more
efficiently because it's sometimes it's
really hard to get the money through
traditional means to fund it as well as
maybe fund and create advocacy systems
incentive systems for communities to
treat these these new medicines as and
get away from the
the people think of them as like oh we
can't touch their psychedelic there
they're legal and they are illegal like
possessing them and all that stuff
legal in the United States in Tulum and
a lot of other places plant medicine
ceremonies are legal but you know
wouldn't it be nice if we could figure
out a way of doing a massive advocacy
campaign through crypto currencies to
end the drug war right the drug war is a
massive trillion dollar fail it doesn't
actually solve any of our problems
people have been killed thrown in mass
amounts with the highest prison
concentration in the United States in
terms of like throwing them in jail for
having a piece of plant in their pocket
yeah right and then wouldn't it be
really interesting if we can figure out
a cryptocurrency advocacy organization
that educates people about what these
types of things are and how do we
reverse those perverse incentives that
your drug war has been basically pushing
on us for 40 50 years and the first
narrative that's been created around
these substances this sounds like my
kind of event you do [ __ ] next year
yeah we are doing another probably a
couple more in the next six months
there's a beyond psychedelics conference
in Prague in cohoon and so we might have
a small event after that just Lessing
thing we'll get back to you on the date
nice I love the idea though it does seem
like there is a little bit of the micro
dosing and discussing crypto though but
ever substances they choose to take but
we was all day event we had we had sort
of panels and talks by some of the most
renowned psychedelic scientists yeah
world yeah we had panels on on crypto
and then we kind of put them together
and he said how do we create these
incentives there was a party and a DJ
afterwards and we had a great time also
no watch are we watch the sunrise on the
beach it was great and we put those
types of people together now if they're
gonna go and worry
other that and and it was just a really
cool brand we didn't do really any
marketing for it but I come back to the
Bay Area and I'm just like oh yeah well
we did crypto psych another you did
crypto psychedelic we heard about that
and I was like yeah that's good yeah
that's a good thing yeah this sounds
great I'm really happy that those two
fields are coming together that's what I
told you the first time that you told me
about it in December I was I'm really
pumped about it
so okay and then let's maybe chime about
this god that's gonna be so impactful
those two will come any other
psychedelics and crypto how about the
general data and privacy right so let's
talk about that quick it's hard to talk
about quick but just in general it seems
as though decentralization is causing
these horizontal marketplace is now of
data more and more open source datasets
more and more machine learning and AI is
able to make more accurate insights into
people's lives because there's larger
data sets and then you're able to give
your own access control to the data so
that way you can choose when you want to
give data how much exactly you want to
give what do you think that this is
going to mesh together with how you're
doing yeah absolutely
so Brittany Kaiser is the whistleblower
for from Cambridge analytics who was you
know working for them as as completely
just won't whistle on all the different
privacy practices that Cambridge America
did with the election and with Facebook
and Google and has made this really one
of her campaigns she's a very good close
friend of mine and so what about that
other guy why we Christopher Riley I've
never met him she worked with him but I
know her through the blockchain
community I came first and then he came
that's how it work I think that it was
going on simultaneous I think it was one
of the people in that in the
News first but I think that there was
the talk of being on the right side of
history
so yeah all of our data is siloed into
these very very large organizations that
really don't give us the how they use
the data it's very non transparent it's
very opaque in terms of how why of when
and how much money these companies are
making off our data and so the movement
here is that there have been massive
abuses of our data used with Cambridge
Illinois because pacifically there's
psychometric profiles to influence
elections and we're not seeing exactly
how these things say a lot of times
these companies know more about you than
your significant other or your mother
yeah they know exactly what you're going
to say and how you're going to do things
based upon your consumer behavior and
all the data that they're collecting on
your devices when the AI knows more
about you than your mother
and your mama's mama simmer down
and so one of the new tools out there
and there's there's a legal framework
there's a legal argument to say that our
data is our property and that we should
be we respect property in the Western
and Western culture and in common law
very much and if our data is our
property we should be the ones
benefiting off of the sale of defend not
some third party and we should know
exactly how and when this data is being
used and then the question becomes
within how does this make money review
the product and so I think that there
were in a turning point here where these
large companies Google and Facebook who
are making billions of dollars off of
our off of our data are may have to
change some their business models and
and and figure out a way of
decentralizing and and democratizing
that data and obviously block chains are
a tool to democratize the use of data
create data marketplaces singularity net
is one that is doing that for our
official intelligence there's a lot of
1.so data wallet is one that's coming
out that
to allow you to own your data and these
ad networks are gonna go away but we
have to figure out ways of controlling
in so we're at the very very beginnings
I think of these these actual
applications coming out I don't think
it's going to be tomorrow that you're
gonna get some sort of token for all of
your data I don't think it's gonna be in
the next month it might be in a year or
two it's gonna move pretty quickly but
the largest thing that we can kind of
say is that if we treat if data is our
property and that's the way we want to
design these new rules and regulations
about how we do this the technology
that's gonna make it possible to treat
that data that way is going to be
blockchain technologies and and and
decentralized data market places so hash
tag on your data there's a change.org
petition going around right now where
you can they want to be able to make it
a front and center point in in the
upcoming hearings and things in in
Washington and so you can you can check
out own your - tag on your data and go
check that out Brian Johnson also really
interesting point especially for this
show Brian Johnson is the founder of
kernel and he wrote a medium post your
data is your property and he's talking
about it from a perspective of if we're
he's kernels the the company that's
gonna make the brain-computer interfaces
and that's what he is and he's saying if
we're gonna eventually hook our brains
up to the Internet and we're gonna be
able to have that that bandwidth there
we must own our data it must be ours it
can't just be everyone else's otherwise
these companies have a direct link to
your brain and all the data that comes
out of it so he's looking at it from the
future perspective love if you're ever
gonna hook it up into your brain to the
Internet you must own everything it
makes it makes sense that with neural
prosthetics or neural laces that from
the brain there should be a barrier here
so that way the information can never
take control of you through this way it
can only go from this way
for control wise that would that would
that's a really good way to look at it
because you never want the control to
come in from that from the outside in
yeah so that's good okay and let's run
you through a couple of the simulation
questions before we end what do you
think about wealth inequality how do we
solve that I think that right now we're
going through the largest shift in
wealth redistribution on the planet it
may not look like it but we're shifting
from a very top-down hierarchical
centralized monetary system and
corporate system to the beginnings here
of a decentralized eco system open
sourcing of money open sourcing of
governance rules and not that the people
at the top won't necessarily benefit
from this but it's about raising the
bottom up and creating that universal
basic income so that's a good way to put
it
the most most of the time we talk about
how crazy the split is and how it is
becoming which it is but at the same
time I think the decentralization is
causing it to pick up some steam and and
and so yeah I think we're going through
the open sourcing of money where
everyone is going to be able to create
different types of currency and [ __ ]
different types of value systems and
that's going to be a massive wealth
transfer to the poor middle class and
through these types of systems we can
incentivize and ensure that those people
are taken care of when the shift occurs
especially with the automation and
artificial intelligence that takes away
those normal jobs so I do think it's a
problem but I do think that we have the
tools now to help solve those problems
do you think we're alone in the cosmos
absolutely not I think that the universe
it'd be an awful waste of space to kind
of quote contact Torvill of what it was
was it was the contractor was it they
said in the movie contact or was it I
forget who said it but it would be an
awful waste of space I think that the
traditional means of taking
pocket and pushing it to the next star
isn't necessarily how the other entities
in the universe would what do it
maybe there's wormhole maybe there's a
quantum entanglement teleporter of some
sort where you can do that maybe you can
beam your consciousness somewhere else
and you're there I absolutely think that
the universe is thriving with life and
continues to evolve and and and well so
you think advanced civilizations are
roaming the cosmos yeah and whether
that's kind of transparent in the like
we can see that in the kind of light
spectrum that were able to view and the
electromagnetic radiation that we're
able to detect I don't know I think that
there's a lot in the universe we don't
understand but I definitely think that
there's a lot of life teeming and people
and don't people entities of one form or
another out there in this this universe
at least I hope so do you think this is
base reality or simulation I you know I
think that this probably is some sort of
weird simulation I think more more and
more I I kind of it's just getting too
intense and I wanted to send you a share
in terms the simulation is breaking down
man the matrix is looking down this
that's what I like it's it's
mind-blowing I and automation and wealth
inequality and all these things this is
Christopher and I always say like if you
haven't looked around if you ever had
your mind blown today you haven't looked
around long enough yeah right you just
mind blowing every day and I just think
that were that the the simulation
whatever this is that we're moving into
is if it is a simulation it's kind of
getting to the the exponential portion
of it yeah we're about to hit the the
peak of the story the climax of the
story yeah and it's will the species
survive on this rock or not or the roll
would go through the great filter or
when we go through the great filter
because at certain times it seems like
we're about to hit that filter and the
who knows maybe life will start back up
in a couple million years you know who
notice if there's some waited for that
to happen you know all right
and then how about what is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world
I think that human creative expression
and and and and connection is the most
beautiful thing in the world I think of
it as like the largest display of human
creative potential and expression is
like Burning Man where your your going
and building a city in the middle of the
desert that is purely built to express
oneself to the forest and but not just
going there bringing that out to the
rest of the rest of the world in the
default reality or whatever is is the
beautiful process but human human a very
human creative expression and creativity
and an art and connection is the most
beautiful thing in the world
I love that and it's also beautiful that
the cosmos produced us to do that where
the cosmos is expressing itself in that
way that way allowing us to do that and
then maybe we end with what is something
that you believe to be true that nobody
else believes to be true
I don't know that no one else believed
just maybe a couple a couple of things I
mean I firmly believe that we are moving
into a very the Golden Age of prosperity
a lot of people focus on the negatives
of the world yeah I believe that we're
moving from into a society that doesn't
have these weird old geographical
boundaries that kind of contain us
whether it be through currencies or
governance systems these are arbitrary
geographical boundaries that we are on
on maps because we couldn't conquer
people more than yet yeah I think I'm
going away yeah and I think that that
leads to massive human prosperity I'm
not a turtle optimist always you know
and so I don't know that see someone
else at least agrees with me yeah I
think we're well on our way to that to
that place but also we need to buckle
buckle in and figure out how exactly
we're gonna get there with more people
right because the worst is yet to come
before we get there I just want to throw
in my two cents there young men Thanks
that that would be that would be and I
think that we've potentially gone
through some iterations in the past
already that we haven't necessarily
fully understand in our history and that
maybe we'll uncover that once we get
some greater technological advancements
and kind of unveil a lot of the control
systems that have been put in place in
in towards to like kind of control the
narrative oh I'm excited to unveil those
of what has been controlling the
narrative let's unveil that over time
let's decentralize everything let's see
is there anything that shouldn't be
decentralized I would say as many of the
power and control systems that we have
we should decentralize our relationship
like companies and and managing specific
types of things can be like we have
people that have
a small hierarchy to make decisions I
think yeah really hard to make decisions
in companies and in in some systems
without a clear hierarchy of control of
who's doing what and that's kind of a
political system as well which is what
we didn't get it to chime too much in on
but next time next time and that kind of
relates with what you were just saying
as well so there should be some sort of
a hierarchical system of decision-making
I think in in private communities there
still should be rule sets that are can
be somewhat hierarchical and you can
always opt out there's a voice and
there's an exit within those are the
types of things your circuit yeah yeah
and so what decentralized as many things
as possible yeah in terms of especially
the control systems of how we operate
with with each other always give people
the ability to create their own system
from the ground up
awesome dissenter net.com Matt McKibben
pleasure me such a see you yeah pleasure
to hang out pleasure to talk this has
been a blast everyone thanks for tuning
in if you had a good time like comment
subscribe do check out the central com
do check us out on patreon if there were
some cool things said during this
conversation share it with other people
get them inspired by the idea of
decentralization go look up all the cool
examples that they're consulting with
right now and think about all those
impacting systems on the planet get
pumped we're gonna be back at you again
tomorrow we're super excited with Alison
Dortmund and stay sexy stay smart stay
inspired
thank you Ron Vargas our producer and
director talk to you more soon peace
thank you everybody
[Music]